hey guys it's Tuesday the second day of
the working week and we have got some
news for you
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss any of our episodes the news that's
going on all the horrible jokes we tell
but for today here's what's going on
[Music]
first up Bioware next IP anthem may not
be the game you're looking for well
maybe it is Bioware released some
details so let's dig into it
Bioware GM Aaron Flynn told CBC anthem
is in his honor we call science-fantasy
very much like Star Wars very much like
the Marvel Universe where you see a lot
of amazing things happening but we don't
worry too much about why they're
happening or how they're happening he
added that Mass Effect is more of a real
hardcore sci-fi IP but anthem is more
about quote having fun in a game world
that's lush and exotic and really sucks
you in anthem is being developed by the
studio behind Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic they worried to star PG of
all-time anthem would be an RPG though
it's an action game set in what Bioware
are calling a vast open-world the game
is also being built around a live
service and features a heavy emphasis on
cooperative play hey Dan you know
remember when sniper ghost Warrior 3
launched and there were a bunch of
problems
oh I remember but the developer CI games
have come out and released a statement
acknowledging those mistakes see America
karinski added that the company spent
too much effort trying to catch up with
other triple-a titles and that the
company made the wrong math considering
the size of their team and the
originally given time frame that
explains the game launching with nearly
five-minute load times on ps4 and the
last minute delay of multiplayer but
don't fret if you're a sniper ghost
Warrior fan it seems the company has
learned from their mistakes and won't be
making another open-world game Tyminski
went on to say we're now moving forward
without any tag attached to our next
project we're planning to make a great
tactical shooter where we can focus on
exciting gameplay some key mechanics and
missions that have depth without all of
the trappings of a large open world
setting see our game since that they
will support sniper ghost Warrior with
updates through 2017
finally Microsoft have revealed the
games with gold for Xbox one and Xbox
360 that she'll be able to pick up in
July here's what you can get for free
kicking off the month is the Jack in the
Beanstalk simulator grow up on Xbox one
and Kane and Lynch - on Xbox 360 graph
is available all month but Kane and
Lynch will only be available until the
15th when it will be replaced by Lego
Pirates of the Caribbean
both of those are playable on Xbox one
via backwards compatibility - by the way
also on the 16th the party game rainbow
will drop for Xbox one owners don't
forget to grab Jun's titles which
includes speedrunners watchdogs and
Dragon Age Origins before they're gone
forever that is it from us today thanks
so much for joining us once again and
let us know what you thought of today's
stories in that coin box and if you've
got a phone make sure you grab the game
spot now happen so you can get the top
ten news stories of the day delivered
right to it
we'll be back again tomorrow so we hope
to see you again